He made me shoot him
kept saying I wasn't real it was almost as if you're a
different person
You're right. He sometimes can become into firmers
Your wig what am I doing here?
You don't remember dark army turned on us. I think I'm next stage two has never called off
Society architect plenty of work to Do I
Can stop this no?
You pull the Ripcord now. They will have won world
catastrophes like this they occur because I'm like
allowed
Something is happening. It could be big
This is going to mark the end of a corp
This is your moment. You cannot turn away now if you pull the right strings a puppet will dance any way you desire
The dark Army needs to know what he's done. You understand the consequences. She's a terrorist
If you don't do anything, they'll be no coming back from this